medicare can get complicated southwest
medical the sponsors of this next
segment offer senior focused initiatives
to help rocky checked in with the doctor
to learn more
dr golco welcome back
thank you so much great to be with you
great to see you as well of course we're
talking medicare it is that time of the
year again so let's just start with the
basics what is medicare enrollment
period
absolutely medicare annual enrollment
it's your time to enroll in or make
changes to your medicare or medicare
advantage health plan and choose a
provider from local network doctors it
began in october and ends on december
7th
and what important things should you
know are medicare eligible keep in mind
during this time
most people want care that they can
depend on at a cost that they can afford
medicare advantage plans offer great
value they're amongst the most popular
and fastest growing plans in the country
you can follow three easy steps
know your needs personalize your choices
and choose your plan
great advice and i understand that
southwest medical has senior focused
initiatives to help you know our
community get through this enrollment
period so what are those initiatives
that's right we're passionate about
helping older adults be as healthy and
as active as they can be that's why we
have so many senior focused extras a 24
7 telephone advice nurse line 24 7 quick
virtual visits
at home visits with our mobile urgent
care unit called dispatch health and a
preventative care coordinator who helps
you understand and schedules health care
screenings as well as other health care
center visits
we also make it easy to access care our
five complete health care centers are
everything patients need all in one
place primary care subspecialty care
labs testing and more
in addition our four locations in
walgreens neighborhood mean you can see
a page provider while shopping or
filling a
prescription there we go and do you guys
have any you know
other ways that patients can follow up
on this topic
any other absolutely
definitely and now is the time to learn
about medicare choices for the coming
year so call the number on your screen
and the optimum care network of nevada
will connect you with a licensed sales
agent to answer your questions and get
you enrolled
perfect well thank you so much dr gokul
we appreciate you it was a pleasure as
always stay well you too
thank you southwest medical associates
for sponsoring this segment they have
locations across southern nevada for
more information on enrollment call
702-608-0964 or visit smalb.com